our next guest spent five seasons as
jane's hotel owning baby daddy and
sometimes boyfriend
on the very popular telenovela jane the
virgin he's out now with a new book it's
called man enough undefining my
masculinity
please welcome justin baldoni
[Music]
may i lead with the thing that everyone
leads with you aren't very talented but
your hair is
just unbelievable you have unbelievable
hair kelly clarkson have you done a hair
commercial yet this is the
question i have i've been well i've been
at home by myself
you know with my family so i have this
is exciting should have made it happen
well thank you your hair is amazing also
blue
i tried we called each other we i was
like you wear your acid wash colors
but you were you were doing well as an
actor and director so why
write a book did you always want to
write a book no actually
i i tried to get out of this book a few
times
[Laughter]
the irony is i wrote a book called man
enough yet i think
don't feel man enough to have written it
and for me the book
is it's undefining masculinity it's it's
it's taking men out of this constricting
box
that doesn't just hurt the women and
gender non-conforming and trans people
um but also we hurt ourselves
and i didn't realize how much i was
suffering and so many men i know are
suffering but we just
we can't ask for help we can't talk
about it because we talk about it we're
challenging the system that keeps us in
the box
yeah and and we're hurting ourselves
we're walking around miserable and
unhappy even though we're putting on a
face that we are so
a book was it was kind of like a 2.0 of
the ted talk it was a it was a way to
put everything on the page and it was
also really healing for me and it came
out because
i really believe that the only way that
we can heal is if we can share our
stories so that other people can find
their own and a lot of us men
are not comfortable talking about these
things and
and it's it's a shame because it you're
missing out on all those extra you know
layers of the onion
with men as well and they're missing out
on it i heard your wife had a suggestion
this is amazing
i heard your wife i know where i think i
know you're good after finishing the
book she read the book and what was the
suggestion tell everyone
it was the first it was the first it was
the end it was the
it was the last chapter and she looks to
me and she says baby
this is really really good but i think
you need to read your own book
oh my god that's some real talk and the
thing is
is it's true and i wrote this book not
as an expert but as somebody who is in
it i'm in the fire i'm
i'm under construction yeah that's the
point and
and she reminded me that i'm like i need
to go back and reread
a lot of the chapters especially the
chapters where i'm reminding other
people that
they are enough yeah you are enough
because i struggle with my enoughness
every single day
yeah but i put on my armor and i'm not
allowed to express it yeah but boy is it
liberating to be able to say like oh my
god i'm a little nervous being on the
kelly clarkson show this is awesome
because it makes us human and we can
have a real connection yeah and what
you're talking about is it's not only
progressing you but it's progressing
society's way of thinking and then
that's progressing the whole world i
think that's a really great conversation
but these aren't new ideas no i know but
they're super old
and honestly women have been talking
about this stuff forever i'm just like
i'm just a
straight white privileged dude that's
talking about it i know but like when
you i feel like it's that thing like
when you if you haven't gone to church i
grew up in church like going to church
and it was like every sunday i was like
is he talking to me like the pastor like
the message i was like wait or if i
hadn't been in a while and i'd come and
i'd be like
i'm like i'm like i'm like who knows i
haven't been here this is about me like
i'm like
and so i start to freak but i think it's
that logical thing that would be
reminded things that you do
know innately but we just don't practice
on the daily because we get lost in how
busy we are and
oh this is how it goes it's okay this is
how i was taught and you don't
we don't progress i think it's really
important i think this is awesome
so everybody justin's book is called man
enough undefining my masculinity it's
out now you got to check it out
yep i'm still here just waiting for you
to subscribe
if you don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever